this is Startalk welcome back to start
talk radio live Marine Memorial Theatre
sketch fest 13 San Francisco California
USA here on stage the brilliant and
funny kid in the hall Dave Foley the
Explorer for search for extraterrestrial
signals from deep in the galaxy seth
shostack and your old friend and buddy
Eugene Mirman I'm Bill Nye the Science
Guy sitting in on a four legged stool
for my esteemed colleague and dear
friend Neil deGrasse Tyson yes Eugene
yes as we went to break yes you asked a
fundamental and important driving
question yes how many light we're like
your weirds governor how many light
winds
no how many light years are we away from
the closest earth-like or inhabitable
planet we don't know but take that
number and don't live five no you good
good I'll double anything you just give
me an hour
not a real thing go on yeah okay well I
mean all you need is at least five star
systems and now you have a good chance
of one habitable planet and five star
systems you'll find those within ten 12
light-years oh really
hmm wow that's that's right with the
Galactic stream so what you don't even
need to fold space you they could they
really could oh well let me just tell
you how long it takes to go ten
light-years at the speed of a NASA
rocket okay Oh probably at least two
weeks maybe years you're right it is
years it's about six also weeks yes I'm
not technically wrong it's just very
inefficient but the number gets big
that's all well there's no way you could
get the answer wrong that's true
it takes about what does it take seventy
thousand a hundred thousand years to go
to the nearest star it doesn't that is
that's even if you punch it so Seth deep
within you know one might ask
astronomers have been looking at the
heavens for a long time we pick a number
for centuries yeah you guys not that I
don't kind of include myself as one of
you guys but let's say you guys you all
have been looking at the heavens for 60
years said accurate 50 something years
50 and some change folk singers for 70
but you haven't heard a thing and this
you haven't heard a thing and this gets
back to a fair mieze paradox if they're
out there why haven't we heard from them
well must better be good yeah
I don't know if everybody in the
audience knows Fermi's paradox unless
they're related to the guy but Fermi
look in a they don't okay let me just
definitively answer that okay don't
don't under don't underestimate me
everyone okay I enjoy his conundrum
better tell us his paradox didn't that
involve his personal and Fermi Fermi was
having lunch one day in 1950 I think it
was it's all apocryphal but he was
having lunch I guess in Los Alamos and
with a couple of physicists and at some
point between two bites of a tuna fish
sandwich he says so where is everybody
he wasn't referring to the lack of
company at the lunch what he was
referring to was the fact that the time
that it would take to colonize the
galaxy if that's on your agenda if
you're the Klingons and you decide you
want to colonize the galaxy and even if
you're Rockets aren't all that fast but
if you stay at it you can do it in you
know a few tens of millions of years
maybe 30 40 50 million years so that's
one that's a long time yeah that's a
long time for you waiting for a bus in
San Francisco but that's not very long
compared to the age of the galaxy so
what he was saying is if there really
are advanced societies out there some of
them one of them would have colonized
the entire galaxy by now we see no
evidence of that and that's why I said
so where is everybody at which one you
let the subject drop and ruined lunch oh
well I'm no I'm I'm still enjoying that
lunch yeah but we know for a fact that
one advanced civilization exists us well
by our own difference yeah yeah we do up
microphones yeah so so not bad look no
wires haha what yeah why this is which
trap that we can tell horses to go left
so we're really pretty good
key ha so so it is one thing to
speculate on intelligent life and hope
that we will find intelligent life but I
for one am thoroughly charmed by the
idea that we go to Mars on a summer day
near the equator where there's some
subterra subs and glacier on Mars that's
using some crazy super salty water out
there and we find some Martian microbes
right it would change the world people
would ride in the streets pitch works
the government wouldn't let them know
about it but with that said yeah if we
found the flu on Mars we would kill each
other
I would kill everyone here yeah what you
know Eugene we've run that experiment
and it turned out you didn't kill him
because to begin with 100 years ago
there's this guy Percival Lowell down in
Arizona with his telescopes cleaning
over canals
Criss crossing the surface of Mars is at
this vast hydraulic civilization 35
million miles from downtown San
Francisco did people ride in the streets
no in 1996 biggest science news story in
the entire year a little Martian
meteorite you may remember this alh84001
and the claim was that there were
Martian Howard Hills
double-o 84 mm but Sears Weekly al HW 84
mm yeah I believe it was 807 3 through
tuna no what is good they all say the
same all right this thing came from Mars
came from Mars and landed in Antarctica
where was very easy to find because it's
on top of the snow right and the only
the only way for it to get it's really a
striking thing everybody when you walk
around there and you find a rock on top
of the ice it takes you a second there's
nothing around I mean there's no rocks
there's no mountains around nothing
granite there's no bulldozer there's no
construction site the only way for the
rock to get there is it fell from outer
space it's really a it or a mischievous
child left it
my first thought would be why am I in
Antarctica because we're exploring well
I don't yeah what do people do I'm from
Canada I don't go anywhere colder than
Canada well is there such a place and
driving us but did this row have things
we thought we're life family are there
was a microlight Mike right right the
claim was the claim by some guys at NASA
and also Stanford University and
President Clinton
yeah well Clinton made the announcement
that by sex addicts and nerds go on you
got a problem that was life both are
wonderful that there was life in this
rock are dead life I mean it was dead
but he's dead Jim but it was a little
microbe and the claim was it was a
Martian from four billion years ago all
right this was front page above the fold
giant font news in the New York Times
for three days four days right liberals
so but people didn't ride in the streets
no no no no they just found out it
wasn't true but it was fascinating
because it's not unreasonable that life
started on Mars this is you guys it's
extraordinary but it's not crazy to
suggest that life started on Mars when
Mars was very wet and then they got hit
with an impact or hmm I mean I'm sure it
was excited also
yep you are all a bag of perverts I feel
so dirty any chance any tiny Hey it's
what's your problem
yes I know okay so so so this thing is
it gets hit with an impact or three
billion years ago
stuffs thrown into space it gets in a
few bits of it get in this extraordinary
mathematical thing called a home in
orbit yeah and you accept another space
circles and lands on the earth and you
and I are somehow descended from a
Martian microbe and let me just say
dududududu 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 it would be an
extraordinary discovery about the course
of events it would really be something
and so along this line if we are all
descended from a common inserts that
which seems a reasonable conclusion when
you look at your DNA and all those mmm
the primitive life forms like anyone my
old boss ha ha yeah and 10 truths so so
it is another question though could have
life started a second time or the time
before us here on earth
and it's if we just had the right place
to look we would find the so-called
second Genesis we are the aliens we're
looking for boom whoa and that theory
has is called what is it called the
second Genesis no this area that that
life came here from from Spain awesome
you transfer me I know
good day fo Lila's tip your server just
try the chicken the low-key Awards so uh
transfer Mia to send seeds across in
Latin yeah but it is it is a remarkable
thing and it's worth studying here on
earth so Seth you are affiliated you do
a lot of work with astrobiologists yes
yeah we have a lot of astrobiologists
yes but is do you feel they have it did
they inform your work at all listening
for radio and light signals and so on
well in the very general sense I mean
they're trying to define you know what
life is how you might look for it I mean
it's easy enough to you know look for
big things but for small things and
probably most of the life in the
universe is microscopic there are more
bacteria in your tummy than there are
people on earth charming really yeah I
believe you yeah no really
wait earlier other than of course
high-fives what are some of the what are
some of ways that you could categorize
something being alive it's it's actually
quite hard to do I mean you can say if
you pick up your 10th grade biology book
if you still have that and you open it
up there it starts out with a definition
of what life has metabolism and life
reproducing homeostasis all this stuff
yeah whatever it is it's all are you the
vid consign of astronomers stroll anyway
ah great bacon stuff maybe or something
else but it you know it you can you can
think of examples of things that fit the
definition but aren't alive right it or
there's things like mules they don't
reproduce it turns out and but they're
you wouldn't you know contest the fact
that they're alive right fire reproduces
but it's not alive so there's no good
definition for life it's no good
definition the current working
definition if it evolves in a Darwinian
fashion what
that isn't even true probably not but if
it's in a Freudian fashion or some other
experiment to look for life so but are
you focusing more on the study of
exoplanets or is SETI focusing more on
planets that might that the have been
discovered yeah there's a website you
can go to actually maintained by the
University of Puerto Rico in which they
have all the currently known exoplanets
that might be habitable there a dozen
that's all well there been a thousand
planets found around other stars
okay roughly thousand there twelve that
it's hard to find the earth-like worlds
cuz they're tiny
they're hard to find so they found
twelve you can go look them up if you
want but I'm telling you they're on the
order of 40 billion or 30 billion or 50
billion would it doesn't matter all
those numbers are the same number
because they're big because they're big
in in our galaxy okay and so obviously
if you find one say well look at this
it's another earth-like world of course
we'll name our antennas in those
directions but maybe you don't have to
if 105 stars has a planet that could be
sort of like the earth and could
incubate a little bit of biology then
why not just look at 10,000 star systems
and 2,000 of them will will have a
planet said did we do something to tick
you off here way to go man
yeah I think you did but I don't
remember what it was sir would you like
a hug no so so so you're saying how long
does it take to look at each star well
as I mentioned that's getting faster
these days you can in depending on how
much is the radio dial you want to check
out it could take you you could spend a
day on each star system you don't want
to do so so when we think of life you're
talking like there's living things in
nuclear reactors there's living things
that eat the lenses of telescopes fungi
so it could be just something we can't
even we literally can't imagine at this
point so can we hear more about things
being alive inside nuclear reactors yeah
there are bacteria that that make a
living in new
reactors they I haven't I've never
really spoken with them but they like
you can't stick it addictive called
radiodurans you can speak with them they
just don't talk back well I say that's
what my concern there Seth was the
preposition with spoken to them yeah
that's just what my mom would do to me
so so along this line suppose we have
microbes on Mars and we're going to go
looking for them as soon as you send
anything there there's a good chance
that we are going to contaminate Mars
and it won't be the good old eco system
that it was right there is some danger
day there people who worry about that
too actually nASA has an office of
planetary protection and I know you're
going to say something no I look it's
fine okay all right what it seemed like
you guys lying to protect planets yeah I
think it'd be dangerous to send kale to
Mars what if they're like this is
amazing but then they develop weed
problems go on what really it's possible
too much kale is not good people be
careful I'm warning you San Francisco
it's it's everywhere
it's nice but just keep it moderate is
what you're saying yeah so the planetary
protection office you know we used to
just bake spacecraft take the Viking
spacecraft put them in an oven and
presume that you would kill everything
but now our electronics and other weight
we don't want to be a kneeling
radioactive material and so on you can't
kill it all isn't most just kind of
shitty I mean no but yes it really a
problem if we can't em yeah it is it
might be a problem not because you use
suddenly you would see you know mold all
over Mars you know that and I'll be like
in a bacon I get rid of 99.9 percent of
them are 99.99% it you know there's so
many bacteria there there's still enough
but the point is that they fall down
there on the surface of Mars and Mars
didn't have any you know ozone layer and
as a result to get cooked by the
ultraviolet so yes it probably
contaminates the area right next to the
spacecraft but you
walk a block away and its pristine Mars
the other thing though for in the case
of surveyor which was there couple
surveyors sent to the moon there was
speculation by the way when I was young
that if we landed on the moon
I say we professional astronauts land
they would sink into dust like quick Sam
and so surveyor spacecraft landed first
these footpads pictures of the footpads
all fabulous and then guys went over
there in their car their lunar rover car
by the way that car is worth millions of
dollars and it's not even locked it's
sitting there on the to it they're
sitting there okay and they they went
over there and unscrewed some stuff and
brought it back and there were bacteria
alive and people speculated that these
bacteria had survived on the surveyor
spacecraft from for three years on the
lunar surface but the problem was
probably dr. s is this correct that it
was stuff that contaminated the guys
just handling it contaminated and they
fooled themselves I'm talking people at
the planetary protection office and they
say it's most likely that it was
contamination introduced bringing the
thing back to earth who knows microbes
are tough you talk to an astrobiologist
about this I did once I said you know
what you got to do to a micro if you got
to get in its face man well yeah you got
to find it that's a moment but if you if
you take I asked if you take all the
biota on or if all the plants islands is
sort of like an experiment for no take
all the biota on earth and throw it on
to Mars
and come back a year later will any of
it still be alive and his answer was yes
said there's certain microbes that
particularly if they can just get
underneath the sand a little bit escapes
out a little from the ultraviolet yeah
that ton of those are called communists
really it's a red planet so so what
this is cool so what what do we do now
to kick to sterilize the spacecraft well
we still sterilize I mean you want to do
that but I think what we do is not worry
too much about the contamination from
spacecraft because it's a that's local
but here's a possible you might want to
consider we're talking about sample
return missions it sounds like you know
Paris Sara's I mean sample return
missions you send a spacecraft one guy
got it you send spacecraft to Mars and
you bring back some likely-looking rocks
and then you look at them here where you
have really good equipment the trouble
there might be that you bring something
back and maybe there are bacteria in
there of some sort Martian bacteria and
could there be some danger to our own
yeah Andromeda Strain kind of yeah it's
radio V great movie so do you have at
the SETI Institute do you have similar
protocol to like to make sure the signal
you're receiving is sterile that is to
say is not military only can't tell you
what it is signal you must have all
sorts of fabulous filters and no red
phone if it sounds like the Beatles you
know it's probably just coming from like
middle America or Britain
I like Britain too I just I just picked
a specific place so how you going to
know it's got it's an intelligent signal
well you the nature the signal that we
look for is is the kind of signal that
transmitters make it's called a
narrowband signal all that means is is
it sort of like one spot on the radio
dial I listen to your local you listen
to this station on abroad or sorry this
program on abroad gas station and it's
at one spot you know it's eight 10
kilohertz or whatever it is okay nature
makes lots of radio noise the Sun makes
lots of radio noise Jupiter make some
radio noise quasars pulsars hot gas coal
gas they all make a lot of radio noise
but it's all over the band it's like
lightning right lightning when you see a
lightning storm you're driving around
your car no matter where your radiation
you hear there was a little guys a
second row knows a little trying to my
lightening impression yeah it's
everywhere it's all over the time so
that's natural radio but et isn't going
to waste transmitter kilowatt hours by
broadcasting all over the dial it'll be
some spot just like that so with that
thought we are going to take a break
everybody if you're listening listening
to star talk here live at the War
Memorial Theatre sketch fest 13 in San
Francisco California we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]